recently given an opportunity to
question some leading economists about
the issues they'll be facing next year
on Capitol Hill they gathered at a
conference hosted by Harvard
University's John F Kennedy School of
Government in Cambridge Massachusetts
this is an hour 40 minutes I'm bill
Purcell the director of the Institute of
Politics here at the Harvard Kennedy
School as the people in this room know
the Institute of Politics Ann Arbor
County School have been hosting this
program for newly elected members of
Congress since 1972 more than 600
members of Congress have been
participants in this program and today
we have present in this room 40 women
and men Democrats and Republicans newly
elected to Congress from all across this
country
I'd offers congressmen and Congresswomen
their first opportunity to spend time
with their colleagues from both
political parties and to talk and think
about the issues that are directly in
front of them and America this morning's
discussion is entitled understanding the
economic crisis leading our panel of
Harvard experts is the Dean of the
Harvard Kennedy School David Ellwood
recognized as one of this nation's
leading Scholars on poverty and Welfare
Dino woods work has been credited with
significantly influencing public policy
in the United States and abroad
he's a labor economist his most recent
research focuses on the changing
structure of American families it's my
privilege to welcome Dean David Ellwood
we are here this morning to talk about
the obvious and most interesting and
important set of issues that will
confront all of you in the first months
and I'm afraid the first years of your
terms in Congress we're very fortunate
today to have a very very distinguished
panel we have three former members of
the Council of Economic Advisers and and
the person that is currently leading the
congressional oversight of the panel the
congressional oversight panel of what's
going on in terms of the emergency
reaction so let me briefly introduce
each of the folks then they will each
talk for about 10 minutes and then we'll
hopefully we'll have a very free-flowing
and open discussion
but it's it is obviously a time of
enormous turmoil and uncertainty and so
we're gonna do our best to provide some
straightforward analysis of it the first
speaker today out is the person directly
on my right jim chant Jeff Frankel is
the James Hart Pell professor of capital
formation here at the Harvard Kennedy
School he directs the program on
international finance and macroeconomics
at the National Guard ACOG research he
is also a member of the business cycle
dating committee you may have heard a
couple of days ago they declared we've
been in recession for about a year at
the same time that he claims it's not
causal all stock markets around the
world fell by 7% so he's responsible for
decline in the total wealth of the world
by 7% the from 1996 to 1999 he was a
member of President Clinton's Council on
economic advisors and his
responsibilities there involved
International Economics macro and the
environment
he has been had a past appointment to
the Federal Reserve at the International
Monetary Fund and many other such places
let me next turn to Greg Mankiw further
on his right he's a professor of
economics he's a professor in economics
department here at Harvard he literally
wrote the book many maybe most
undergraduates nowadays who when they go
in and take an introductory course in
economics will use principles of
economics and that's a book that Greg
has written this is of course it's sold
over a million copies it's been
translated into 20 different languages
he's also written one of the premier
intermediate textbooks on macro
economics I was asking him how much it's
being revised right at this moment it is
a remarkable time he's a prolific writer
himself his research is on everything
from price adjustment and consumer
behavior financial markets and he served
from 2003 to 2005 as chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers under a
church of U Bush he too has been
affiliated with many institutions
ranging from the Federal Reserve Bank of
Boston the Congressional Budget Office
Elizabeth Warren on my left is the Leo
Gottlieb professor of law at Harvard Law
School she teaches
tract law bankruptcy and commercial law
of course an issue that suddenly is one
of the most popular courses in all of
Harvard those she's always been one of
the greatest teachers she's certainly
written frequently and testifies often
on issues ranging from credit laws to
personal bankruptcy she's one of her
main contributions and focus of much of
her work has been focused in happening
to the middle class and indeed she's
written numerous books but for example
one is the to income trap why
middle-class mothers and fathers are
going Brolin she's a member of the
Federal Deposit Insurance corporation's
Committee on economic inclusion but most
importantly she on November 14th of this
year was selected to chair the
Congressional Oversight Panel on the
emergency economic stabilization Act
Nancy Pelosi was was quoted as saying
the panel will provide independent and
ongoing oversight to ensure that the
economic recovery program is managed
with full transparency and strict
accountability so it's very useful to
have Elizabeth here with us today so
she's often she's currently recognized
as one of the 50 most influential women
attorneys and the like finally Robert
Lawrence my far left is the Albert L
Williams professor of international
trade and investment here at the Harvard
Kennedy School he's also involved in a
number of other places like nashing con
do Garvey cannot research like he was a
member of the Council of Economic
Advisers between 1998 and 2000 under
President Clinton his research is
focused on trade policy
he's currently serves as the faculty
chair of the practice of trade policy
executive program Robert King school
which Broughton brings straight
ministers from around the world to talk
and look and explore
he's been on advisory boards at the
Congressional Budget Office overseas
development council and so on he too is
the author of many books and articles
such as crimes and punishments
retaliation under WTO regionalism and
multilateralism and the like so each of
these folks has much to offer and what
I'm going to first ask is
professor Frankel and professor Manku to
give us a little bit of a sense of how
we got where we're at and begin to touch
on where we're heading what we're trying
to do and then I'll turn it over to two
professor warren and professor lawrence
to give us some additional insights so
let me start with Jeff Frankel now I am
you may watch me passing notes I'm gonna
be a strict timekeeper here Jeff is
right has some slides here and he's
known for his slides I will say no more
Jeff well Thank You Dean Elwood I'm not
sure whether you mean I'm known for the
the quality of my slides or the quantity
but in this case I have kept it to three
slides I hope to as it's my way to you
see those slides to try to set the stage
for this panel by reminding us of where
we are in the economic crisis and try to
say something about how we got that way
although nobody thoroughly understands
the economic crisis despite the title of
the of the session the just to remind
you the subprime mortgage crisis hit in
the summer of 2007 and for quite a while
the hope was that it could be it would
be contained was the the words that
often came reassuringly from the Federal
Reserve and elsewhere well that turned
out not to be the case and various
indicators of economic activity started
to go into decline the one that is sort
of most precise is payroll employment
which is illustrated in this graph the
top graph is a total labor force the
middle graph is his employment number of
jobs and the bottom graph is the
unemployment rate payroll employment
peaked in December 2007 and since then
we have lost about 1.2 million jobs the
unemployment rate in the most recent
month available was six and a half
percent in October that would be on the
on the payroll basis and is risen
quite a bit from over over the last year
by the way tomorrow is the day the first
Friday of the month is when the Bureau
of Labor Statistics releases the numbers
for nobody
and we'll see what those are well as as
dean Elwood mentioned I'm a member of
the NBR business cycle dating committee
and on Monday we made the declaration
that oops that the recession had started
December 2007 that should be a
one-year-old may be a Freudian slip
because most people's reaction is what
only now a year later you're announcing
it may be implying that we took too long
but on the other hand maybe we took
maybe we did it too soon because many
people think the definition of a
recession is two consecutive quarters of
negative growth and we haven't had that
yet but the definition there we have
some official status is what the NBR
business cycle dating committee says it
is for a recession and and we look at a
variety of indicators Greg Mankiw was on
this committee for maybe eight years but
it's one of those committees that's good
to be on but when I went doing an
expansion because it never met that was
a during the longest expansion in in
American history in the in the 1990s
anyway the fact that the recession
started in December 2007 means that it
is already longer than the preceding two
recessions which both were eight months
in length it means that it is also
already longer than the average post-war
recession which is ten months in length
length now the record is 16 months which
was the two most severe recessions so
far 81 82 and 70 1974
everybody's forecast and I'm now not
speaking as a member of this committee
the end of our business cycle dating
committee but if you look at the
forecast of the Federal Reserve or the
IMF or the private forecasters pretty
much everybody expects the the recession
to continue at least until the middle of
2009 which would mean that it will be
the longest post-war recession so by
that measure worst worst recession
nowhere near the Great Depression that
that's uh let me just put that one aside
okay how did we get here
well this is my attempt to put just
about everything I had to leave some
things out into one slide and and this
is my last slide you'll be relieved to
hear so at the top
I have five relatively fundamental
causes or origins and I welcome
amendments or Corrections from my fellow
panelists one problem is at least in
retrospect monetary policy was too easy
roughly between 2003 and 2005 there was
this period when interest rates were
rock-bottom and it's this is much easier
to say in retrospect IIIi wouldn't
necessarily give alan greenspan who is
chairman of the Fed at the time too hard
a time on this given what was known at
the time and there's areas other than
monetary policy where I think he made
made made worse mistakes but in
retrospect it was too easy and it gave
rise money went out of Treasury bills
and because they didn't pay much
interest and they went into everything
else housing stocks commodities emerging
markets and so on second the financial
markets way under estimated risk in the
years 2004 2005 2006 and I have in mind
precise precise things that go into
formulas when the people in the
financial markets a hotshot traders
trade options and and junk bonds and all
the rest they have they have models that
tell them what the degree of risk is and
for technical reasons that I won't go
into
well basically cuz they were just
looking backwards and things had been
calm in the past and so they way under
estimated risk when I think one could
have reasonably said there's a number of
very great uncertainties in the horizon
on the horizon which have to do with
some of these other factors
number three is failures of corporate
governance and it's here where maybe
some reforms over time would be
appropriate
one would be executive compensation and
the heavy use of options to compensate
top executives which may give them an
incentive to to take take more risk than
we want we like risk-taking but too much
and it's particularly with regard to
short-term profits and disregarding
longer-term health the fourth
fundamental factor was been going on for
a long time American households save too
little by international standards saving
ratings very low and then borrow too
much and during the housing boom they
kept
I figured well I've got a lot of wealth
in my house and so they consumed a lot
and they even borrowed against the house
used to use their their house as a ATM
and the in the in the cliche and a lot
of people took out two mortgages that
they couldn't really afford in the
longer term unless housing prices
continue to go up at a very rapid rate
which was I most of us think we are
never in I was never in the cards the
fifth fundamental problem is a federal
budget deficits which in my view the we
got set on a path in 2001 through the
tax cuts that were passed in 2001 and
2003 and the path of spending which was
triple the rate of growth of spending of
the preceding administration we got set
on a long-term path of fiscal
irresponsibility that's that would be my
interpretation others are welcome to
give different interpretations alright
now we go down to the next level of of
causality excessive leverage in
financial institutions and that's that
blue box and some of this is is perhaps
structural and could be addressed by by
reform higher capital requirements for
financial institutions and the problem
is not so much with banks as with other
institutions so we're basically doing
the jobs of banks but not formally
regulated as banks the case of banks we
have minimum requirements for reserves
that you have to hold and capital
adequacy and all that although even
there one of the things forms we might
need is at the international level in
Basel Switzerland the central bankers
meet and there's an agreement called
Basel 2 where they tried to improve the
system by setting for any big
international banks capital adequacy and
I think in retrospect those methods of
setting those levered levels of leverage
and the capital requirements need to be
adjusted basically they were to
procyclical and I see all three of those
factors the monetary policy the
underestimation of risk and the failures
of the of corporate governance and
particularly in the regulation and the
financial sector is feeding in to
excessive leverage and financial and
well then we got the stock market bubble
and we got the housing bubble the stock
market bubble really came in two stages
the late 90s and then and then a renewed
one in up until a year ago and the
housing bubble grew slowly and and
reached its peak at maybe 2005-2006
and in in line with the arrows I've
shown there I am trying largely to
attribute those bubbles to the factors
that I have already named well where
there's a bubble there's usually a crash
following and we've had both the stock
market crash and the housing crash and
those are the those are the black
explosions they're indicating that
there's some some problem
the first stock market decline was in
the year 2000 but then it recovered to
its previous peak and and of course
we've seen new renew crashes a new stock
market has fallen by roughly half over
the last few weeks and and by the way
it's it's true that world market stock
market capitalization fell 7% on the day
that the NBR business cycle dating
committee declared the recession but I
looked at the pattern during the course
of the day and I don't think it's our
fault because it didn't happen within
the two hours after the announcement it
happened in a different different part
of the day and of course we weren't
telling people anything that they didn't
already know well the combination of the
housing crash and the stock market crash
I think caused the financial crisis
together with the fact that financial
institutions were so highly levered that
they didn't have a margin of error and
so when the assets they held lose by
lost value they had to retrench very
rapidly and the financial crisis I have
dated from mid 2007 it's obviously still
continuing but I think we've moved into
a new phase the recession which now
formally started at the very end of 2007
it's almost a year old and and I'm I'm
predicting here probably
uncontroversially that will continue
into 2009
it'll be the recession of 2008 to 2009
essentially in addition to the financial
crisis there were some other
contributing factors I have the oil
price spike off to the left there of
2007 and 2008 now it's hard to remember
there was only two or three months ago
that the prices of oil and other
agricultural commodities and mineral
commodities were at in many cases
all-time highs across across the board
of almost all commodities and that that
was contributing I think to the to the
slowdown as a result of the global
recession probably the that's the reason
the prices of oil and other commodities
have fallen a lot over the last few
months and if you got very good eyesight
you'll see that I have a few
contributing causes to the oil price
spike in the first place rampant growth
in China and other East Asian countries
and the world in the aggregate so that
increased demand for oil plus I have a
political instability in the in the
Persian Gulf and among other oil
exporters so there's some other factors
off to the right there but that's really
for the longer term which is a distinct
set of problems in the current recession
so I'll stop there thank you that turned
out to be a great chart so thank you
next I want to turn it over to Greg
Mankiw no thank you
so the like to be here let me start by
congratulating the newly elected members
of Congress and thanking you for the
service to the country that we'll be
doing in the next few years talking
about the economic and financial crisis
is particularly difficult too because
it's one of those areas where economists
do not see with this see the world
through a single lens there's lots of
issues by the way the economists do
agree on if you could get a bunch of
economists in the room to talk about
international trade 80 or 90 percent of
them will be free traders if you get
them in the room to talk about global
climate change 80 or 90 percent I'll
tell you we should put on a carbon tax
but if you get a bunch of economists in
the room to talk about what we should do
in the face of a economic crisis like
we're facing now and the macro economy
you're not going to get a consensus you
may get a few more opinions and you have
economists so so I think it's very hard
to for anyone
to figure what's the right thing to do
as simpler I mean I I just I agree with
a lot of what Jeff said about the causes
of this not all of it but most of it but
let me sort of try to boil much of it
down to a much simpler narrative what
happened in the past decade or so was
that lots of financial institutions made
a bet that housing prices nationwide
would not fall by 20% now yes why didn't
make such a bet well it's a large part
because housing price has never had
fallen nationwide by 20% well it's not
quite sure they had in 1930s that was a
long time ago and it happened in Japan
1990s that's far away so if we don't
look too far in the past or too far away
geographically it's just impossible for
housing prices to fall so they made the
bet they wouldn't they did and they end
up losing lots of money having lost lots
of money they then found themselves with
much too little capital to continue
their main goal and objective in the
economy of moving resources between
savers and borrowers and the whole
process of financial intermediation
broke down things are made all the worse
no they lost lots of money it wasn't
sure exactly who lost the money wasn't
sure where the bodies were buried and
the tremendous uncertainty about how
this would all end I think it's
contributed to a sense of panic and a
great loss of confidence which in turn
affected not only housing prices but
also stock prices so the question is
what do we do now I think there's sort
of a consensus among most economists
although probably not all that we should
basically look at the current situation
through the lens of a particular theory
proposed by John Maynard Keynes in the
1930s and the basic theory was that we
have recessions and depressions when
there is insufficient a great demand but
simply people start spending enough to
keep people fully employed economists
typically divide the demand for goods or
services into four categories and if you
look at each of those different
components of gross domestic product
it's hard to find demand coming from
anywhere so the first component 70% of
the economy is consumption it's very
hard to see households picking up the
slack for demand going forward as Jeff
pointed out Americans typically have a
low saving rate and many economists said
for a long time talk about how
households should save more and we
should do things to try to encourage
saving this may not be the best time to
do that though because the problem is
insufficient demand and getting people
to save rather than spend something it
can contribute to the economic downturn
and if you're looking at households
they're facing that idea they're gonna
start consuming a lot more and then over
the next six months or a year is pretty
implausible people are opening up their
401k statements and seeing they a lot
poorer than they were a year ago I've
been looking at a house of value and
deciding that the home equity line that
they could use to finance the next
vacation is not gonna go as far as it
did
consumer confidence is very close to an
all-time low
by many of the certain of surveys that
people do so it's very hard to see that
that consumption is gonna pick up much
of the demand slack going forward
investment is also weak in particular
residential investment has fallen off
because basically what's going on in the
housing market measures of residential
investment are down by more than 40%
over the past few years business
investments also not looking so good
these financing is hard to come by
businesses looking at their stock
pricing it's gonna be hard to raise
money in equity markets they're looking
to their bank and saying huh it's not
looking so good to getting Bank bank
financing they're looking at corporate
bond yields and they'll and they've
those look pretty unattractive to so
it's unlikely that investments going to
pick up the slack six months ago the
story was that foreigners would pick up
the slack the third component of GDP
then I'll talk about his net exports and
for a while it looked like the dollar
was depreciating making us goods cheaper
abroad and net exports were booming and
it looked like that that was gonna save
the day you know we consumers will stop
spending here and we've investment to
fall off but then our net exports would
pick up and that would save us from a
deep downturn ironically as the crisis
United States has spread to the rest of
the world
investors have looked for a safe haven
that safe haven is the United States in
many cases so capital has been flowing
back the United States it's caused the
dollar to appreciate in the past six
months which means our goods are more
expensive abroad and so it's hard to
seen over the next six months or year
the net exports are going to be a source
of
demand and that leaves the fourth
component of gross domestic product
which is government purchases and a lot
of people are looking to the government
as being the demander of last resort
other thing that person the institution
to pick up the slack and start demanding
goods and services but nobody else wants
them I'll get to back to the pros and
cons of that in a minute okay so how are
we gonna fix this problem that we're
heading into this is deep downturn well
there's three basic things we need to
think about one is fixing the financial
system the second is monetary policy and
the third is fiscal policy so let me say
a few words about each of those the
Treasury has been coming up with this
the plan as you've been reading the
newspaper to try to sort of fix the
financial system so to an outsider looks
like they're flailing and changing
course all the time
I actually don't blame them for that in
the sense that it's a deeply complicate
what's going on we're not completely
sure what's going on and sometimes
experimentation and Follette and
flailing is the best you can do this is
the plan a was to buy tack toxic assets
from the bank they switched they
switched and then the encouragement of
many economists to use the tarp money to
recapitalize the banks through equity
injections to basically make the make up
for the losses that the banks had
suffered this is not losing money for
taxpayer because there we are painting
ownership stake but some more of an
investment for the taxpayer but the goal
is not to not to be an investor but
really to get the financial system
working again and now looks like they're
thinking about making loans directly the
discussion in today's paper but
mortgages working stiff of - now
nationalize Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
is to provide mortgages directly and one
thing it's been very troublesome is that
while interest rates on government bonds
has been coming down mortgage rates have
not been coming down and the the the
Treasuries is looking at ways at dealing
with that monetary policy is I think
monetary policies the first line of
defense in in dealing with global
economic downturn the good news about
monetary policy is that the guy running
it Ben Bernanke is as good as it gets I
think is a widespread consensus among
professional economists that Ben
Bernanke is the right man for that job
at his time he has tremendously high
esteem among academic economists which
is where he then comes from and I think
thing that's true
both filly of the Republican Party like
myself and an economist associated with
the Democratic Party Ben is a very good
reputation the bad news of course is
that he's as clueless as the rest of us
about what's the best thing to do is but
he's but he's also been very creative in
what he's been doing the fear about
monetary policy in the current
environment is that it looks like it's
starting to run out of ammunition that
is a traditional tool for fighting
recession is the cutting interest rates
and the particular interest rate they
targeted something called the federal
funds rate which is a interest rate that
banks loan money to each other and the
overnight rate that's pretty close to
zero which is the lower bound for
interest rates and people start feeling
that I mean a monetary policy maybe
loses power in that environment but Ben
has actually written even before this
environment he's written papers and
giving speeches about creative ways to
stimulate the economy and deal with this
monetary policy when you're facing this
lower bound of zero and now he's
implementing a lot of the ideas that he
said previously so involves things like
getting longer-term interest rates down
he's even talked about the Fed buying
mortgage instruments and I think was
very clear that he's willing to act very
creatively and he will continue to act
very creatively in to get monetary
policy fight fighting this global
economic downturn the third tool is a
fiscal policy which is presumably where
you guys come in you're in very short
order soon as your take take take take
your new jobs this to be basically
textbook answers for how fiscal policy
can prop up aggregate demand this
increased government spending or cut
taxes and the one of the issues you
would be facing is to what extent you
undo one into what extent do you want to
do the other the textbook answer
including the one that you find if you
open up my textbook is that for
stimulating the demand for goods and
services you actually get more bang for
your buck by an increase in government
spending than you will for the same
dollar figure for tax cut that is for
the textbook answer you'll hear that
from a lot of economists I don't think
is actually clear well that's completely
true by the way because well that's the
that's the answer that comes out of the
textbook theories that we teach there's
some evidence to the contrary there's a
paper written just a few years ago by
a bland shard who's now chief economist
that he IMF he wrote that when you back
in professor at MIT and what balance art
finds is that a higher government
spending against the crowd out more
investment
whereas tax cuts tend to stimulate more
private investment and that's not
something that difference is not
something you'd expect from textbook
Keynesian theory but doesn't be true in
the data similarly some recent research
building on the black charred research
by Harold uhlig at the University of
Chicago also finds that so the tax cuts
are more stimulatory than spending
increases so I think this is it very
interesting debate about to what extent
you want doing the spending science what
I sent to other than the tax side and I
don't think the economics profession has
a very clear answer on that question now
the big flying ointment about fiscal
policy is the long-run fiscal outlook we
have the big problem you can face longer
term not over the next two years but
over the next ten or twenty years has to
do with the aging of the population as
the baby boom generation retires and
there are more people drawing on Social
Security and Medicare and its health
care costs continue to increase the gap
between government spending and tax
revenue is going to grow larger and
larger anything you do in the short run
steam late the economy is probably
involved increases in government debt
which is gonna make dealing with a
longer-term fiscal problem of the aging
of the population and the Social
Security and Medicare unfunded
liabilities even harder so that is in
some sense the the big fly in the
ointment that's why my own view is that
monetary policies in the front line here
rather than fiscal policy
I'm just getting economy out of the
short-run downturn but fiscal policy may
have a role to play as well in my last
minute let's talk about how bad things
are gonna get I like Jeff I'm not
expecting a great another Great
Depression but a but about one very
quick study there was a study written
about five years ago maybe ten years ago
now by a professor at Yale and what they
found was that in the 1930s as the Great
Depression was unfolding people did not
expect a Great Depression to unfold it
was completely on forecast at the time
when they were sitting on panels like
this
people are saying it's not gonna be like
another Great Depression what's worse is
that that professor said what if we had
the modern tools of economics it's
forecasting then we had their data but
our modern tools could we a forecast the
Great Depression and the answer is no we
could not so I'm not for I'm not
forecasting of the Great Depression we
should take that with another a very
large grain of salt
thank you very much so thank you it's a
pleasure to be here today and I hope I
get a chance to meet all of you um I
want to start back with Jeffrey's chart
and Jeffrey had a little chart in there
that said he said there are five things
that got this started and he had one
called saving too little borrowing too
much and I want to talk about that for
just a couple seconds you know this is
not like a 100 million American families
woke up and said I know let's quit
saving and let's go borrow what happened
is there's been an enormous shift in the
economics of the middle class over one
generation so that basically I'm gonna
do the really quick sketch of this and
we could all go back what we've had is
we've had flat incomes for fully
employed males fully employed male this
year makes about $800 less in inflation
adjusted dollars than a fully employed
male was making the early 1970s and what
we've also had is rising core expenses
expense that the family budget has
actually shifted so that families and
inflation adjusted dollars over this
30-year arc are spending less on food
less on clothing less on appliances less
on furniture they're spending more on
electronics but it adds up to about
three hundred and thirty dollars nobody
went broke over this I've more on
electronics it's not consumption goods
where the real Rises have been and all
across this art has been in housing in
health care in child care and
transportation and taxes because they
have two people in the workforce when
you add up the total number of dollars
that families are spending so we've got
families with flat incomes rising Cork's
census and so what if they done the
average one income family back in the
1970s was putting away think about this
10% of their take-home pay they were
putting away in savings
the median American family today has two
people in the workforce and what have
they been putting away in savings for
the last four years
zero they put away effectively
statistically speaking nothing so they
put a second worker into the workforce
they spent everything that she brought
to the table they spent everything they
used to spend in savings right they they
just stopped doing that and kept sending
it out the door and the third part they
went into debt and they didn't go into
debt just to get small bathrooms and
granite countertops
they went into bed into debt to buy the
median American family moved from five
point eight rooms to six point one rooms
they picked up either a third bedroom or
a second bathroom but not both and they
they borrowed lots of money to do it and
then let's just be clear in order to
meet the rest of their expenses they hid
the credit card so they hid the credit
cards they financed more on the cars
they hid payday loans every way you had
to go so these families now we have 50
million American families today who
cannot pay off their credit card bills
on average they owe two months of income
and they're paying interest on that
income paying interest on that
outstanding bill the average family kind
of back of the envelope calculation is
probably spending somewhere in the
neighborhood of about sixteen hundred
and fifty dollars a year just on
interest in fees a whole new expense
that's not even accounted for when we
talk about family expenses next time you
look at the Consumer Price Index remind
yourself they assume you paid cash and
that you have no credit expenses
outstanding okay so that's where the
American family stands the question then
becomes how do we get into this crisis
and because I've been instructed to I'm
going to kind of short circuit here to
try to use it as a way to talk about
three things that we might want to be
thinking about over the next year or two
for changes that might be hell
and the first I want to talk about is I
want to talk about consumer financial
products because in my view that is
where this crisis started this crisis
started in part back in the nineteen
late 1970s early 1980s when we kicked
out a law that we had had since colonial
times and that was usury well we'd had
use recaps all across the United States
they predate the American Constitution
we had them in every state in one form
or another and then through the
interpretation of a banking law that had
been passed in the post-civil war era in
1979 the United States Supreme Court had
to decide what's an obscure language
meant I'll take you through it if you
want but the bottom line was it
permitted banks to set up shop in one
state with a very high usery cap and
then export their credit cards in this
particular case all around the country
and use that home states UserA great as
a consequence of the CEO of one of the
very large banks went to South Dakota
and said would you be interested in
raising your usery cap I can promise you
700 new jobs and they did and they did
if you've ever wondered why your
Citibank bill is mailed back to South
Dakota there's the answer and the
consequence is South Carolina and
Oklahoma and California lost the ability
to control interest rates within their
jurisdictions
home mortgages soon followed with a
congressional act in the 1980's no
public debate now the consequence of
this in a high inflationary period
immediately in the 1980s had very small
consequence but over time it began to
change how consumer lending looked
consumer lending had frankly been a
pretty pokey business
you made modest profits but they were
quite reliable that's what the mortgage
industry looked like the default rates
on mortgages you're absolutely right was
about 1% of course back in the 1970s the
median first-time home buyer was putting
down an 18% down payment
for the past three years the median
first time homebuyer was putting down
anybody one another number zero zero and
gosh nobody could have guessed that
default rates would have gone up when
people had no skin in the game from the
beginning so so let's just be clear
about this now the second thing was part
of how these products began to change is
they began to change the average
according the Wall Street Journal the
average credit card contract back in
1981 was a page and a half long because
it had very limited variables right
here's the interest rate here's the
penalty fee that happens right pay it
that's the deal
the average credit card contract
according to The Wall Street Journal by
the mid to early 2000s is 31 pages long
and if you've ever read the 31 pages all
you have discovered those additional 29
and a half pages did not get added to
help the consumer we shifted to what I
call a tricks and traps pricing model so
that consumers look at three things this
is what the guys who actually do the
market research talk about they look at
the overt interest rate the nominal
interest rate the one on the front of
the envelope they look at the prizes of
frequent flyer miles out you're nodding
you have them frequent flyer miles cash
back contributions to a golden retriever
rescue fund and they look at
relationships that's a company that
would be warm and fuzzy this is a
company that signals success and those
are the three things consumers buy
credit cards on so the new model becomes
put those credit cards in the hands of
every man woman child in America a few
dogs and you'll make a little bit of
money off every one of them in the
transaction fee every time somebody uses
that credit card to merchant has to pay
something back to the credit card issuer
so so you'll make a little money but
what you also have is a series of
lottery tickets because somebody will be
a little late somebody will stumble
somebody'll get a little behind somebody
will go over limit fee somebody will
will trip up somewhere in that twenty
nine and a half pages and that's where
the sweet spot is that's where you make
all the money
sort of gamed happened in the mortgage
industry on I know how we'll make more
money in mortgages said many many people
on Wall Street they said we'll sell
people mortgages only make real modest
percentage rates but that's because
they're just thirty year fixed
instruments they're not very fancy I
know what we'll do
we'll sell them mortgage rates that
effectively will return fifteen percent
rates of interest how can you do that
well you can only do that if you give
them mortgages that have a lot of tricks
and traps like teaser rate mortgages
your bill will only be $400 for the
first twenty four months you hit the
twenty-fifth month and the interest rate
skyrockets and there's a prepayment
penalty if you have to refinance into a
new one very profitable instruments okay
so here's the short version of what I
want to say about that we are regulating
consumer financial products absolutely
the wrong way
usury may not be the right answer
anymore we may have more sophisticated
ways to do it but the real point is we
have lost our regulatory way in this
area and the American consumer has paid
for it my view is we need something
along the lines of the Consumer Product
Safety Commission every can of soda
every candy everything we touch breathe
handle in America is regulated for
safety at some level you don't buy
apples that are covered with carcinogens
you don't buy cosmetics that have ground
glass in them
you don't buy infant car seats that
collapse on impact and yet financial
products which believe me our products
they are marketed like products they are
treated like products financial products
are not governed by that rule they're
governed by the rule of contracts hey
you read the 31 pages you negotiated it
fully with me and you meant to be bound
by that clause on page 17 we don't hand
people a wiring diagram when they buy a
toaster and say you're supposed to
figure out that right over there in
circuit 24 these things were likely to
burst into flames
instead we regulate them for safety and
toasters then compete to make them
better for consumers they give them
better colors they make them cheaper
they give them all the little razzmatazz
ins that make cute noises or do whatever
they do
and financial products we have a
competitive market but it has competed
to add additional tricks and traps that
make this expensive for consumers and
mislead consumers about the kinds of
risks they're taking it's happened on
mortgages it's happened on credit cards
it's happened on payday loans we now
regulate are you ready for this stop and
think about the fact that in the
financial services industry we regulate
by who the issuer is so if you're have
if you have a product that's issued by a
federal bank
it'll be controlled by the OCC if it's
issued by a federal thrift it will be
the OTS if it's a state bank it will be
the state charter and they have separate
the consequence is we have created a
situation of regulatory arbitrage and
that is where a company in effect says
to its regulator hey um you're giving me
tough rules over at OTS they'll give me
a better deal down and up in South
Carolina they'll give me a better deal
or South Dakota or California so that
what happens is they move around for
better treatment and since the
regulatory agencies including the OCC in
Washington derive much of their budget
from those they regulate we end up with
a circumstance where the American family
is simply left unprotected so I want to
make a pitch that this is an area where
we need some regulatory reform to level
the playing field for the American
family I'll say just two more just to
say they're here as placeholders we need
to talk about foreclosure mitigation
because the drop in the market is now
creating its own problems that's
creating further drop in the market and
then one last pitch that I want to put
in here when we're talking about the
economy let's remember however you want
to look at them every one of those
American households 117 American
households there are little economic
units whatever you can do for the
economic unit is something you do to
improve the economy not all solutions
start at Wall Street some solutions
really do start at Main Street if
American families had better health care
they would be in better financial shape
if they had better childcare they would
be in better financial shape these are
the areas where we're seeing enormous
growth if they had a way to send their
children to college and a way to work
off those loans that kids take out early
on then the American family would be in
better shape and it starts there if the
American family is healthier if those
hundred and seventeen million units
don't need to engage in deficit
financing aren't paying twice as much
for health insurance in
inflation-adjusted dollars than they
were paying twenty years ago if those
units are back on their feet
Wall Street and the rest of the world is
back on their feet and in my view any
attempt to try to fix Wall Street to try
to fix the rest of the economy without
trying to help those American families
directly is doomed to failure thank you
very much Robert Lawrence I too want to
congratulate all of you on your election
and also join my colleagues as members
of the dismal science in forecasting the
rather grim prospects of our our economy
I think the question many people are
asking is are we actually going to
relive the 1930s now if you look at the
1930s and you ask economic historians
why they feel policy failed at that
period I think you'll hear three answers
the first is that basically the banking
system was allowed to fail there were
runs on banks and little was done to to
remedy that problem the second was that
there was a failure actually to
appreciate depression economics and the
role that the government had to play in
its fiscal policy that it fiscal policy
at that time was not sufficiently
expansionary they weren't enough
increases in spending
and the third component that I want to
talk about relates to trade policy in
1930 as you'll recall there were massive
increases in tariffs in the United
States known as the smoot-hawley tariff
the u.s. raised the tariff rate average
tariff rate to about 60% and and this
looked quite rational because people
wanted to keep the spending at home they
didn't want it to trickle out into the
rest of the world but it turned out that
this set off a response in other parts
of the world where countries also raised
their tariffs and what we got was a
downward spiral in a global demand and
global trade just plummeted over the
next three years now historians debate
as to whether the Great Depression was
caused by the smoot-hawley Tariff sand I
think there's probably a consensus that
they didn't but there is no doubt that
they made matters a lot worse now if we
look at our policies today I would
endorse what was said earlier when it
comes to the question of the of the
banking system
we've we've had a collapse in our in our
financial system but we've seen our
policymakers act with a lot of ingenuity
trying not to repeat the mistakes of
their predecessors I think when it comes
to fiscal policy although hearing Greg
makes me a little worried because I
believe that fiscal policy has to play a
major role that we need massive
increases in in in both on the tax side
and on the spending side not only by the
way in the United States but all around
the world we need that fiscal injection
to compensate for the withdrawal by
consumers and the increase in their in
their savings but I think on both of
those fronts we've seen action now an
open quest
is what about the trade area are we in
fact going to see a repetition of the
errors of the 1930s Oh are we there to
going to learn from those mistakes
well you might argue that this fear is
unwarranted because we've actually
improved the global trading system
immensely we've lowered barriers around
the world and we haven't just lowered
the barriers but we also have a trading
system a multilateral trading system
based on the international rule of law
and so countries have legally committed
not to raise their tariffs beyond
certain bound rates so we are secure in
that respect in addition the g20
countries met a couple of weeks ago and
they pledged not to increase their trade
their trade barriers nonetheless we
should not lose sight of the fact that
there are going to be a lot of pressures
there are going to be a lot of pressures
to do things that keep the demand at
home in fact if you looked at the
December 8th cover of Businessweek
you'll see that it it asks the question
can Obama keep those new jobs at home in
a sense the question is are we are going
to take measures to try to prevent the
spill overs from our economy into the
rest of the world it's a very rational
response just as it is for individual
consumers to cut back just as it is for
banks to want to stop lending all of
those are very rational of behavior but
they accumulate in the economy and they
make matters worse we live in a highly
interdependent global economy in which
we have structured the economy on a
global basis and so efforts to try to
inhibit the free flow of goods and
services across international
at this time could truly prove
devastating if we needed any reminder of
our interdependence it's evident in the
way in which the slowdown has built up
all around the world for instance if you
look at freight rates freight rates are
down by 90 percent
if you go and look at Long Beach
California you can see the automobiles
piling up on the dock so what's
happening is already a cumulative
slowdown in which other countries are
starting to cut back the United States
is cutting back at spending and so we
really have to be wary of of mating
matters worse in this area there are
going to be a lot of a lot of pressures
on all of you to try to act to ensure
that the stimulus that you provide only
Falls domestically but I think this is a
great error it is far better to create a
virtuous cycle in which countries prop
up rather than to repeat the experience
of the 1930s in which they dragged each
other down we're debating our what our
policy should be not only in the
financial area we're effectively many of
the banks have now been nationalized but
also of course with respect to the auto
companies what form should our
assistance be are we going to assist
them in a way that only helps the
domestically owned companies or are we
just gonna what will we do for the other
companies many of whom are major
employers in the United States itself so
I think we need to be mindful I also
think we need to be vigilant as to what
our trading partners are doing we need
to hold their feet to the fire just as
we need to be restrained we also be
mindful and we need to use the vehicle
of the
trade organization in monitoring what
they are doing we're seeing troubling
signs in other parts of the world China
very recently decided that the they were
going to give their exporters a new set
of rebates it turns out they are
entitled to do this under their
value-added a tax system but nonetheless
it's a gesture which I don't think it's
trading partners should simply accept
but that I just cite that is just one
example of the many measures in this
that are likely to be taken in this area
but I also think we need to take care to
use the opportunity of our stimulus
program to undertake a number of reforms
that will help our workers back at home
we have had a very tough time for the
American worker we've seen very sluggish
wage growth over the last six years
basically for both blue-collar workers
and college-educated workers we've also
seen immense dislocation even prior to
this slowdown in our manufacturing
sector
we lost three million manufacturing jobs
between 2000 and 2003 and in fact we've
lost an additional almost 800,000 over
the last year now in the minds of many
Americans International Trade is
responsible for this
in my view actually trade is a part of
the story but it's a relatively small
part there are many other reasons for
these declines nonetheless we do need to
help American workers directly I think
through a supplementing their take-home
pay with tax cuts and also with respect
to programs that deal with dislocation
our unemployment insurance system hasn't
been improved since basically its its
introduction and in particular
we ensure wages but we don't ensure
benefits so people lose their health
care when they lose their jobs ideally
we will have universal coverage on
health care but at a minimum we need
health care insurance insurance so that
people who do lose their jobs do not
lose their health care insurance I also
finally think we need to appreciate that
change occurs in communities not only in
at the individual level and a really
important part of the stimulus package
needs to be assistance to state and
local governments but over the longer
term I believe we need mechanisms
whereby state and local governments can
ensure their tax bases so that if they
are hit by shocks like plant closings or
crop failures or natural disasters of
any kind they can also put in a claim
too often we have a we basically have a
system in which local governments are
required to balance their budgets and so
what we get is a downward spiral as
drops in their revenue give rise to two
cuts in in spending so this is an
opportunity to put us on a much more
sounder footing and with that I'll end
thank you thank you very much to all
members of panel now open it up for
questions we have plenty of time for
comments and so forth I'll do my best I
suspect there'll be more questions than
there is time just a reminder when you
do have a question if you would be sure
and push your button so the red light
comes on and when you're done with the
question please turn it off so we don't
hear you say well that was a dumb answer
so let me first light and I can't see
everybody's nametags from here also so
let me just start down here let's see
millions of questions but I'll try to
pray I'll just give two how about that
can we actually my request would be to
try and go at one way and indeed we
there's a search standard policy we have
around here which is a good question has
three elements
it starts with identifying yourself
it's a short containing only one thought
and it ends with a question mark so if
we could follow those principles that
would be a big help
Jared polls from Colorado is really
directed towards uh Elizabeth it was
moving from from the macro and a lot of
issues you talked about to something
that's on all our minds right now and
it's relatively close to the ground can
you tell us a little bit drawing upon
your expertise in bankruptcy what it
would look like if Detroit were to go
through the default option which would
be some form of bankruptcy chapter 7 or
11 what you know what would a
restructuring look like if it went
through that process as opposed to a
government orchestrated process well I
will try to give just a really short
answer on that and and that is um
bankruptcy by itself is not going to
cost jobs bankruptcy by itself is not
going to shut down the business
bankruptcy is just a process and it's a
process of an automatic stay to keep
people from collecting it's a process of
giving a structured way to try to
reshape the business and get management
to come up with a plan for how they're
going to devise this business on the on
the other side the two big the three big
issues as I hear it or whether or not
they can get what's called post-petition
financing there's a big question about
whether or not that might be government
funds or some combination of government
and private funds or only private funds
the big advantage to being a post
bankruptcy financier instead of the
financier just before they file for
bankruptcy or at some time is that
post-petition financing takes priority
over all old financing so it it infuses
cash into the Pacific creates an
incentive it's been there all along to
create this incentive to infuse cash
into the business the second thing that
happens is management loses a lot of
control in bankruptcy uh they're real
high replacement rates of CEOs and top
management it's not uncommon to bring in
what's called turnaround management
people who come in and Risa's or
businesses and the third thing that I
understand is an issue in the auto
industry is it is an automatic default
on everything and while the company is
protected when there's an automatic
default on everything
that's what the automatic stay does no
creditor can come in and seize anything
there's a question in this world we have
created of collateralized debt
obligations and credit default swaps and
so on there will be winners and losers
who have made various bets on what's
going to happen to GM's bonds to GM's
other obligations so that's just kind of
the key part ultimately the real
question is is there a plan to build
cars that people want to buy and if so
can these companies get there if they
can there will be jobs and if they can
they will become profitable at some
point if not there won't be jobs and
bankruptcy bankruptcies just a tool if
you don't have a plan bankruptcy isn't
going to give you a plan and if you do
have a plan bankruptcy can often be
useful in getting you there my name is
Laura Richardson and I'm from California
and in particular I represent both the
Port of Long Beach and Los Angeles which
covers 45% of our nation's cargo so my
question is to you mr. Lawrence you
talked a little bit about our
responsibility as trading partners and
our trading partners responsibility I'm
working on legislation right now and one
of our concerns from trading is that
clearly our trading partners are
utilizing Canada through Prince Rupert
to now avoid coming in through our ports
and also you have Mexico which is in
Collin net that's now looking at doing
the mega port so clearly there are what
some people would view our attacks on
our economy and so I wanted to get your
thoughts on what we could do to be
supportive but yet still we have to
protect our base as well well my view is
that we need to facilitate international
trade because we benefit we benefit from
being able to sell abroad and from able
to buy from the rest of the world and a
key dimension is is is the costs of
getting the goods
and getting the goods out and in order
to do that our economy is going to
benefit from the most competitive
infrastructure systems that we have and
so to be honest with you I think we want
to see a lot of competition in these
infrastructure systems whether they are
located on our border and run by our
trading partners or whether we run them
ourselves I think in the long run we're
going to be beneficial benefited by that
now we need to be mindful though that we
don't hinder our ports and in particular
we have to make those borders operate
smoothly a lot of regulatory reforms
have to have to take place but but I
think in the in the long run it's it's
gonna have to be an open competition and
that your port is competing with these
other ports for for entry into the
United States and in the long run you
have to ask what's gonna make yourself
what what is gonna make you more
competitive answer the question so my
question is are you in support of us for
example allowing trucks from Mexico that
don't have the same regulations in terms
of safety I recently went to the port of
Barcelona where only five containers are
being inspected which is clearly not in
accordance with the 911 recommendations
so it's one thing to say we want to have
open borders but if we're not receiving
the protections that we require then
there's a problem and there's usually a
cost associated with them no I do not
think we should give up on our safety
regulations or on our health regulations
or on our national security regulations
so we need to insist that those are
adhere to but once but once those are
done I think we should have an open
competition so I'm not in favor of
weakening the regulatory structures that
keep keep our products safe and and and
indeed our country saying
my Kaufmann Colorado I think my question
is that is it assume like though my
question is the more we is that the more
we engage in trying to reduce the pain
in the recession that we're in through
stimulative spending or other policies
is it going to handicap this economy in
the future I mean versus going through
the pain now I don't I don't see any
virtue of the pain so I'm not there are
there some points of view that
recessions have cleansing effects and
they leave the economy stronger in the
end I don't I don't see any evidence for
that I think it's among professional
economists at some an already view I
think most economists they do do we you
can to avoid the recession the question
is what is it and to what extent is it
is it thanks fixing a financial system
to what extent monetary policy to what
extent is it fiscal policy watching
wonder scholars the great scholars with
a great depression has been Bernanke as
you probably know another great scholar
with a great depression is Christy Romer
who's taking over to be chairman the
Council of Economic Advisors and the new
Obama administration a lot of her work
was on the Great Depression it looks at
what got us into it and what got us out
of it her answer is that what got us
until was bad monetary policy and what
got us out of it was better monetary
policy so I think her work suggests that
monetary policy has to have a large role
doesn't mean that there's no role for
fiscal policy but a very large share I
believe of the answer is gonna have to
come from a reserve system on fiscal
policy there is this sort of paradox
that what we need I think there's a
pretty broad consensus as Gregg says so
what we need is a fiscal stimulus both
in the form I would say of tax cuts and
spending increases in the very short
term but on the other hand we already
had a very severe fiscal outlook for the
longer term and it's going to get worse
over the next 10 or 20 years with the
retirement of the baby boom generation
which is already starting and Social
Security and especially Medicare etc and
so it's a hard message to get across but
we need to combine stimulus today
with measures and I don't think we need
we should wait three years before
putting in those other measures I think
it should be part of what the plan is
today to try to move us back onto a more
sustainable and responsible path for the
longer term so on the tax side the
president-elect Obama campaigned on tax
cuts for the lower 95 percent and on
raising tax rates are allowing to expire
it's not the tax breaks that that
benefited so much the upper 5% well I
would say give the tax break and I think
this is where they're heading give the
tax break to the lower 95 percent of
American workers now and and hold off a
couple years on the raising in taxes
back to where they were ten years ago on
the upper 5% and similarly with fiscal
policy with spending policy designed
from the beginning a plan that gives you
stimulus in the short term and to be
frank this is just this was done wrong
ten years ago it was stimulus that
helped get us out of the 2001 recession
that's partly why the recession was so
moderate but it put us on a disastrous
longer-term fiscal path in my view on
the question of how to solve a long-term
fiscal problem when you pull
professional economist and they've
actually done this solution that
economists like the best is raising the
retirement age for Social Security for
Social Security and made it presumably
apply for Medicare as well but perhaps
but there's a there's a widespread
consensus that's the right thing to do
among professional economists well this
one does one difference between us and
you guys we have tenure you guys got to
get reelected every two years
economists don't run for office go very
far let me turn to Elizabeth I didn't
want to make one mention for any members
watching on the audience or whatever
that don't we use this term fiscal
versus monetary policy a lot understand
that fiscal means the things that the
gut the federal government does in terms
of its spending and tax policy monetary
tends to be the things that are done by
the Federal Reserve Bank in terms of
affecting how much money supply there is
setting of interest rates and the like
and so mostly the Congress can affect
fiscal policy what the Federal Reserve
Ben Bernanke does and so forth is
monetary policy though of course one
helps oversee the other and so there are
interactions Elizabeth whom you want to
comment on uh yeah I was just going to
say too that economists
like it because they have jobs that have
no heavy lifting in it so not everybody
wants to hit 67 trying to do that kind
of work but but I just gonna make a very
brief point and and that is there's
another way to understand about some of
these these spending questions just
another I'm gonna just gonna take a
little kind of microcosm about what's
going on and that is to look at the
question of what to do about these asset
bests securities based on mortgages
right we've got this real problem and
the real problem is that the stream of
revenues that's produced from all these
American families had been valued up
here that's where the stock market had
valued them put it everybody's portfolio
been sold and sliced and diced and so on
and the problem we've got right now is
that the stream of revenue simply won't
support that kind of valuation and so at
some point those two things have to be
brought into alignment now we can put a
bunch of money in and we're talking
about this putting a bunch of money in
to try to prop up this market to try to
buy these securities and kind of create
a floor unto them but if the reality is
that the families who are who are
pumping that money out month after month
after month
can only support the valuation off that
is really down here then those two
things have to be brought into alignment
and that's just pain and that just
happens there going to be some people
who are gonna lose when that happens
they're gonna be some investors who are
gonna lose when that happens but
spending money to prop up markets at
least in my view is the losers game and
it's worse than just kind of zero some
losers game it's a loser's game that
then saddles these people with tax
obligations into the future so they have
even less capacity to produce going
forward so so I'm just gonna make a
narrower point then then the economists
about you've really got to be careful
about watching what the money's being
spent for and and what the intent is I
keep wanting to hear what the what the
line is how how it was supposed to go
from A to B to C to fix a problem and
I'm I'm real I'm real nervous about some
ways that that goes
I'm Anne Kirkpatrick from Arizona and
Dean Elwood I was really interested in
your presentation yesterday about the
changing demographics and sort of
following up on Elizabeth's answer
are there any models that really show
what a healthy US economy will look like
in 25 years based on those changing
demographics in other words it seems to
me we should have a strategy to build a
strong economy looking forward 25 years
and that's where we should be putting
our efforts and if there are models how
do we how do we get our hands on those
great question I mean it's it's some
sense economists favor decentralized
decision-making as opposed to a model
with the economy looks like 25 years it
looks like sort of top-down central
planning so we don't have a model quite
in that sense I think the big question
about the economy 25 years from now is
how we can even you guys gonna close the
gap between benefits that have been
projected from my our general retired
and the tax revenues that you're gonna
get collected from my children and the
big question another way so the way I
say it to my heart freshmen who I teach
I say look my generation of baby boomers
have promised ourselves a certain level
of Social Security and Medicare benefits
and we've promised you're going to pay
for it and so the question is how how's
that gonna really gonna work out
are you really need me those benefits
and pose much higher tax rates on my
children or are you gonna cut back on my
benefits that's a political question was
much as an economic question was really
the question you'll be facing in the
next decade I would add just one little
tiny other piece to it about the
modeling question that that alarms me a
the answer is no it's obvious nobody's
got a model for this and and not really
thinking a whole lot about it but I'm
gonna add a another piece that has me
worried because I think nobody thinks
about it with every succeeding year not
every succeeding generation but every
succeeding year we load up young people
with more debt student loan debt and
credit card debt basically to start
their lives
so I started
my life with $1,800 in NDEA loans and
paid those off by teaching public school
for for a couple of years our children
are starting the game of life at 22 not
not dead flat broke but dead flat broke
is still 50 miles in front of them
they're starting so far behind because
of what we're doing with debt to young
people and if we want to talk about
models about modeling this out
I am deeply frightened about what it
means to keep trying to run an economy
where every succeeding group of young
people coming into it to work are
starting out with these kinds of debt
burdens as they make them their
decisions about what jobs to take
whether or not to go for further
education whether or not to get married
and buy homes and have families that's
that's part of the least of the modeling
we're missing down here hi Chris Lee
from New York my issues more so on
I heard free-trade sounded like it was
everyone in this room was an advocate of
that as am i but concerned about fair
trade and you look at China and the fact
that they have a currency that is
undervalued in the market pegged to the
dollar what what areas can we go with
I'm not a huge fan of tariffs but we've
got to bring them to the table to allow
our manufacturing to compete what do we
do or what options do we have to try to
push the Chinese along to float that
currency well I I am I see the Chinese
exchange rate as as as only a symptom of
a deeper issue that is a challenge that
we're now facing basically the United
States has been overspending as we've
heard and we've been stimulating the
world economy and we've been borrowing
from the Chinese in order to do that
because the Chinese have been saving
huge amounts of their incomes they've
had rapid growth but in China people are
deeply insecure if you
lose your job you have no benefits
you're only allowed to have one child so
no one's gonna look off to you when you
retire and so what we've seen is a
massive increase in in the savings rate
in China and what we do need is a is a
as we look out over the medium term is a
restructuring in which we save more and
they spend more in which they generate
more of their growth in terms of
domestic demand and less of their growth
through an undervalued currency and and
and exporting but if we simply tell them
to change their exchange rate without
changing their fundamental spending
behavior I think we could see deep
problems in in in China so so I think we
need a work I do think we need to call
them by the way I am not so convinced
that a weaker listless stronger Chinese
currency is the answer to our problems I
think most of the goods we buy from
China if the Chinese currency
appreciates we're gonna buy from other
developing countries because many of
those goods are no longer made in the
United States and we don't compete
heavily with China in export markets the
kind of goods we export aren't the kind
of goods that China exports so I think
other developing countries should be
more concerned about the Chinese
exchange rate than we do so I think it
needs to be part of a discussion with
China but there has to be a fundamental
change in their underlying policies so
that they don't have these huge
unsustainable surpluses which are the
counterparts to our huge deficits so I
agree that the Chinese renminbi should
should appreciate but mainly in their
own interests as Robert says and by the
way it has appreciated somewhat already
I think Congress has made a huge mistake
in placing so much emphasis on the
exchange rate with China there are so
many other issues that are more
important that we should be negotiated
with China and to begin with we don't
have much leverage I mean people better
get used to this we are the world's
largest net debtor they are the creditor
we owe them we don't
have that much leverage the leverage we
have we should say four things we really
need like help with North Korea and all
kinds of you know proliferation issues
etc etc in economics what we most need
them to do to push them along doing more
than the currency is to expand demand to
do the structural shift away from
manufacturing which they're really good
at and export a lot and it's time for
them to move into services and
healthcare and provide a safety net for
their own people that would help their
people and that would help the
international situation as well
Roberts quite right if the currency
appreciated the things we're now buying
from them we'd buy from from Southeast
Asia instead okay right up here Steve
Driehaus from Ohio there's been a lot of
talk recently over the last several
months in Washington about the
regulatory and by environment the
financial services sector several of you
talked this morning about laxed
regulations around you know risk around
you know consumer protections I'm
interested in knowing from the panel if
in fact you believe we need to
strengthen regulations and financial
services and specifically what you would
target well I'm easy I would answer for
me is just absolutely yes and the way I
would start is I would start by
acknowledging that Congress can't do it
one regulation at a time you're you're
very poorly suited to do that because
money is the most innovative place to be
if you tell me we can't have 15-day
default clauses we'll move to Universal
default clauses will you know we I just
have to change words on a piece of paper
and these these instruments change and
it's hard for you to find out about them
you don't find about about them until
much much later and quite frankly this
is a really lopsided lobbying area there
are many billions of dollars to be made
on the side of regulatory laxness in
this area at least in the short run even
though not in the long run and nobody
really there's no organized group on the
other side that matches that so from my
perspective what this means is we really
need to acknowledge
consumer financial products our products
nobody can read 31 pages you got to get
rid of the tricks and traps pricing and
for me it means we do the same thing we
did back in the 1970s when we
established the Consumer Product Safety
Commission that nobody read toaster
wiring diagrams or analyzed the paint
and we had something that then could
could change over time and I want to be
clear here when we talk about
regulations its regulations so that we
can have markets work better so that
people can understand what it is that
they're buying and they can assess the
risk appropriately we want to talk about
personal responsibility quite frankly I
don't know how anybody has personal
responsibility on 248 pages of mortgage
loan documentation for what your own
lawyer will say don't read it just sign
there sign there sign there and sign
there so this is really about making
those things work in the same way that
toasters work and car seats work and so
I think it's an area that is ripe for it
frankly I think it would have happened
in the 70s except we still had usury
laws and so long as we had us realize we
didn't need this form of regulation
there was there was no advantage there
was no tricks and traps capacity because
there just weren't enough percentage
points in there so I think a nimble
agency is the right way to go in
consumer products I have other but but
let me give more space to others
regulation so I'm not sure I have any
disagreement or even comment on just
said I'm not sure that those issues
would have particularly saved us from
the housing bubble and the current
crisis were facing and I think the issue
of regulatory reform is I think a
longer-term issue that's gonna have to
haven't slow or where's issues like
fiscal stimulus is issues they're facing
I'm day one already so I think in terms
of staging I think you need to think
about the regulatory structure you know
on a longer-term basis but anything but
anything about the macro picture
absolutely immediately could I just say
one thing though in response to that the
idea that we have a long time to think
about consumer
financial product regulation is simply
wrong reciting of the December eighth
cover of Newsweek take a look at the
December 15th I think in its cover of
Newsweek the subprime predators are back
they haven't gone away this the problems
I'm describing have not disappeared one
way credit card companies have decided
they're going to weather this storm is
they're just raising everybody's
interest rates including the interest
rates on good customers who've paid on
time mortgage lenders are figuring out
that in their old capacity they were
selling one kind of product now they're
selling them to FHA they're trying to
they're moving around up we can't fix
this problem from the top down alone if
you keep chewing it families at the
bottom bloodletting at the bottom we
can't rebuild this economy so frankly
I'm I'm as alarmed and and and want to
push as quickly for some basic
protections in this area just just the
minimum and the notion I really want to
say strongly yes we could have averted a
large part of this crisis if we had had
a basic safety regulation on mortgages
I'll tell you one factor if you couldn't
have done prepayment penalties so that
every time you priced a mortgage it
needed to be for the company that was
pricing it revenue positive from the
first date not because the law said it
had to be but because economics would
say it had to be because you took out
that prepayment penalty that gets hidden
that nobody understands how you that
lets you do tricky pricing if that had
happened we never would have inflated
the housing market in the way that we
did and Wall Street would never have
poured the billions of dollars that they
did in because it would never have been
such a profitable product and supported
it so I think it is directly related to
our crisis that we're running out of
time we'll take a few more questions let
me be an inappropriate moderator and add
one little thought here wearing my role
as a deans at which is we do have a
history of setting up regulations at
times of crisis that is not a pleasant
history and I think the strategy of
thinking about this is we and the other
important lessons about Marcus is when
you squeeze one place it squeezes back
some place
but I like about Elizabeth's idea is
saying now let's not write a bunch of
regulations that just say okay nope Rico
I get it the message is no prepayment
that will solve it I think I think
regulation by overlapping congressional
committee is not a great strategy so the
question is how do you craft something
that does in a fairly rapid pace really
think effectively about how to manage a
system that by the way is managed by
people as you there is so much money
sloshing around that a comma in a
different place changes everything
and believe me your lobbyists know that
so thank you Dean
I'm mark Schauer from Michigan great
panel Elizabeth thanks for trying to put
a human face on this in Michigan
economists are projecting the
unemployment rate to exceed 10 percent
next year I mean people are really
hurting I do want to push Robert
Lawrence a little bit on the trade issue
obviously it was a big issue in a lot of
campaigns and industrial states I
learned about negative externalities
when I was in undergraduate school from
people like you and whether it's the
environment whether it's worker safety
whether you know we're also concerned
about intellectual property we've lost
entire sectors of our economy what
specific things can you recommend that
wouldn't hurt overall trade in the
global economy that can be inserted in
trade agreements to protect some of
those and and create a fair balance of
trade well youyou mentioned intellectual
property and in fact those rules are in
the trading agreements now so so trips
as part of the WTO rules and stronger
intellectual property is in every one of
the bilateral agreements that we have
negotiated we have now we have
environmental and in fact labor
standards that have been introduced into
trade agreements
the Peru agreement which actually got a
lot of support from both Democrats and
Republicans has much stronger measures
on that score they're included actually
currently in the Korea agreement and the
Colombia agreement so so I think we've
made a lot of headway there remains an
open question about the NAFTA where the
side agreements were much weaker and
president-elect Obama has said that he
wants to to reopen that I think it's
it's gonna be it would be dangerous to
reopen the whole agreement but I think
those side agreements certainly could be
negotiated I don't think these are
things we can decide unilaterally I
think we have to make the kind of
efforts to to get our trading partners
to go along and I think we've actually
made significant progress although we
needed to continue to do more okay
hangout time what I'm gonna do is take
three questions without answers and then
just go down the panel to answer them so
if we could I'll do my best to try and
just pick three rattling go ahead you
you madam can't see the name I'm sorry
thank you that's all right Suzanne
Kosmas from Florida I appreciate you all
being here today and particularly
Elizabeth as was said before your focus
on the sort of individual and personal
responsibility and the family as an
economic unit I think that's a an
important point to be made I want to go
back to the beginning though
and Jeff's slide and the and the five
top boxes that look almost like the
perfect storm for the economic crisis
that we find ourselves in right now and
try to assess slightly the the not who's
at fault because I don't know that that
gets us anywhere moving forward but in
terms of monetary policy and what you
call under estimating the risk in
financial markets I wonder if you could
more correctly say not only under
estimated but under regulated with
recognizing what you said about our
regulating in times of crisis we are
dealing now with an
precedented situation where a private
market free enterprise businesses are
coming to the taxpayer and asking to be
bailed out to the tune of 700 billion at
any one given time which could be more
as we all know what at what point do you
say to yourself this isn't simply a
decision going forward about whether we
adjust monetary policy or fiscal policy
or even the the regulations with regard
to credit cards and mortgages but how do
we hold these free-market companies
accountable for the situation in which
they find themselves
that is to say the whole house of cards
of our American economy about to fall on
the taxpayers having being charged with
holding it up if you could address that
our questions and then we'll go to down
here yes we see from San Juan Puerto
Rico quickly on the spending side what's
gonna come quickly before us is the
stimulus package any specific comments
about the components of it as outlined
so far by president-elect Obama and his
team and last right down here Steve
Scalise from New Orleans one of the
things that was brought up during the
last financial bailout was the role that
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac played and
attempts by Congress in the past that
had failed to try to regulate them and
changes to the Community Reinvestment
Act in the late 1990s that may have
encouraged them to give loans to people
regardless of ability to pay
going forward what changes and reforms
would you suggest making to Fannie and
Freddie to to change their role in this
whole housing market mortgage bubble so
three short answers what do we do about
regulation what do we do about the
stimulus package and wanted to do about
Freddie and Fannie less than one deep
questions meet sec she's combined the
regulation and the fannie question he
was the story of of Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac is a very sad one in the
sense that there were a lot of
economists who had talked for a long
time and both the both republican
economists
the clinton ministration like people
like larry summers but warned about the
proper prospects that housing market
with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and I
don't think the whole story what's going
on now that's part of the story and it's
not a happy story and it's a it's not a
happy story in part because the process
became so politicized and one in
thinking about regulation going forward
thinking think hard about the regulatory
structure there'll be a lot of
discussion about that over the next few
years for sure but the fear is that it's
gonna get to become politicized and go
down the same route that Fannie did
where every all the economists who knew
there was a problem waiting to happen
and it happened but the political
process failed us for reasons I think
are pretty clear at this point now on
this on this spending side you know I
think infrastructure spending makes
sense to the extent that the particular
projects pass a cost-benefit test in
Keynesian economics in 1930s Keynes used
to say well it easy just hire people to
dig holes and fill them up again that's
that's stimulating the economy that's a
good thing well I don't personally think
it's a good way of money
I think infrastructure spending makes
sense if each of the projects makes
sense from the standpoint of having
benefits that exceed the costs otherwise
I'm much rather prefer see tax cuts
things like you know bonus depreciation
which we saw in the last recession which
I think did help some research out of
University Michigan suggests that things
like perhaps a payroll tax cut for a
year or two in order to encourage job
creation I think there's a lot of ideas
that are floating around that's issues
that you guys will be fed debating in
the next months very quickly so I guess
the common theme on these three
questions is the point that in a crisis
it's an opportunity a terrible thing to
waste it's been said but as ardena said
they usually they often are wasted and
often the yes the answer is more
regulation but often it's a knee-jerk
reaction that makes things worse rather
than better it's got to be the right
kind of regulation so to run through the
tree quickly Suzanne Cosmos Florida yes
I think that regulation to reduce the
amount of leverage and increase capital
requirements for example the originated
to distribute model on mortgages that
the mortgage broker sells the more
mortgage
blends of money and then since it
some sell someone else it doesn't keep
any of it at all or capitalization
capital requirements with regard to
credit default swaps etc there's but but
the Devils in the details it's tough
stuck on where where the money should be
spent there's a usual critique is
something like infrastructure by the
time you get around to it it's too late
number one and number two is a lot of
you know look at the Big Dig here I mean
often it's not very efficiently done
shall we say but there it can be done it
can be done and I would return money to
the states give money to the states who
have infrastructure investment projects
that are already underway that they're
having to stop so that would get going
right away
and yes make sure that it's a that's
something we need for the longer term I
agree with the Greg not spending money
just to spend money but currently there
are cities and states closing schools
shutting down subway lines starting down
bus lines shutting down good investment
projects and and and we should get the
money to them quickly so it could be
spent again also environmental
investment lastly on Fannie and Freddie
I'm with Greg I'm an economist first
choice would to say be to say government
really shouldn't be in the business of
trying to shift the American public away
from renting towards home owning to
everybody but but the problem is nobody
except economists believes that everyone
else thinks the more homeowners are
better so I would say accept it that
that's gonna be a political goal keep
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in the
government because the problem is you
pretend that it's not there for a public
interest and it's a private shareholder
and yet the government is there backing
it that's how we got into trouble if
you're gonna do it keep it in the
government so next thing I turn to
Elizabeth I want to warn you Elizabeth
is has to literally run out of door in
about one second for an airplane now
many of you would like to talk with her
she's gonna be wandering the halls of
Congress because you hired her so I'm
sorry that she's gonna have to run
quickly go ahead okay so I'm gonna I am
gonna try to be quick though how do you
hold companies accountable my answer at
the beginning is if they want our money
then they have to make themselves
accountable they have to tell us how
they're going to be made accountable we
cannot be the softest chump out there
who will lend money just because it
comes from the government we should be
the toughest guys not the
easiest on the stimulus package I just
want you to remember something it's a
little thing in Parade magazine that's
the kind of stuff I like to read they
did a little survey how are you going to
spend your stimulus check 60% of those
responding said I'm gonna use it to pay
off credit card bills that doesn't
produce jobs that didn't move it back in
the ways we talked about so think about
that if it's just cash as opposed to
jobs or other things that need to be
done Fannie and Freddie you right what a
sad story Fannie and Freddie were often
a force for good and I want to make this
little point because it may have slipped
away Community Reinvestment Act subprime
was invented long before we got here but
subprime used to mean in the 1990s it
paid about 80 basis points more for your
30-year fixed mortgage than prime you
paid a little premium above prime to
cover the risk and that's what it was
about and that was very useful that
helped expand homeownership with very
low default rates the trick in Fannie
and Freddie all was they for a long time
because they controlled the money kept
some kind of regulation in the mortgage
market not overtly but through their
kind of market devices and then what
happened is people found out how to do
an end run around Franny Fannie and
Freddie and go straight to the markets
the minute that happened Fannie and
Freddie had to make a decision either
they could be the clean lenders forever
and they were going to shrink market
share because of all that was going on
on Wall Street or they were going to
compete and that is that they were going
to offer and take products that got
increasingly dirty and Fannie and
Freddie chose the second path now they
made a lot of money in the mean time but
it brought them to where they are and
that suggests I have to say I agree with
Jeffrey here that that suggests you've
got to keep it in-house in the
government that this mixed notion of how
we were going to get upsides from the
marketplace it tells us it frankly just
didn't work so I'll stop there yes if to
come back to the issue of regulatory
reform I think the general what we've
been hit by is not simply the fact that
we have poorly regulated our banks but
the shadow banks the substitute banks
that have emerged
have become extremely potent sources of
risk and I think the general principle
has to be that if you are too big to
fail if you as a financial institution
or have the capacity to impose social
costs you have to be regulated so it
seems to me we have to expand the scope
of who we regulate because it's too late
after the fact when they come calling
for help in terms of stimulus package we
have to think about where is the where
is the money most likely to be spent and
it does seem to me that state and local
governments given the fact that they are
they balance their budgets so when they
get more money they spend it so they are
logical target the third the third group
of course are people are unemployed
because they have hopefully transitory
reductions in their income if you give
them more money they are going to spend
it so my prime candidates would be the
state and local governments and use the
opportunity to reform the unemployment
insurance and I concur that the
integration of private profit motive
with the social role for Fannie and
Freddie was a disaster we have to
separate those two those two aspects all
right
could I ask the members to reconvene in
that room just the room of the Alison
dining room where these been previously
just join me in there right now